[Musique]
la maison sexo s'agrandit après 18 mois
de travaux le groupe inaugure un nouvel
environnement de travail à son siège à
Guy en cours découverte du site dans ce
numéro pour la première fois en
île-de-fance un concept de coiving voit
le jour le Premium est un ensemble
d'immeubles hybride mélant coiving et
coworking découvrez la start-up
sititroom incubé au ski cube elle
propose une solution collaborative
centrée sur la
cartographie on commence ce numéro avec
l'inauguration d'un autre bâtiment cette
fois-ci c'est le nouvel environnement de
travail de la maison Sodexo allez
suivez-moi je vais vous faire
[Musique]
visiter cette année le siège de Sodexo
France fait P neuve après 18 mois de
travaux l'entreprise inaugurée mardi 17
octobre son nouvel environnement de
travail son nom la maison Sodexo 18000
m² entièrement rénové qui a un objectif
se sentir comme à la maison on s'adapte
au mode hybride de du nouvel
environnement c'est-à-dire que les gens
travaillent 3 jours par semaine ici au
bureau et 2 jours chez eux donc quand
ils viennent ici ce qu'il recherche
c'est des espaces de collaboration des
salles de réunions des espaces aussi de
convivialité donc ce qu'il recherche et
l'interaction pour faciliter ses
échanges Sodexo a donc dou ces salles de
réunion les espaces du bureau se veulent
confortables le principe faire en sorte
que le salarié se déplace en fonction
des tâches qu'il a à effectuer par
exemple sur les plateaux on va trouver
donc on est en open space mais sont des
open space pas trop grands à taille
humaine pour être convivial chaleureux
et en fait on a un nombre important de
bulles de une de 3 enfin de capacités
varié en fait pour que les gens puissent
s'isoler ou se réunir au contraire le
but c'est c'est vraiment de que les gens
en fait puissent travailler
confortablement au rez-de-chaussée de
nouveaux espaces ont été créés le tout
dans un décor de village une
conciergerie un pressing ou encore un
coffee shop ont été mis en place pour
les salariés pour ce qui est de la
restauration Sodexo a mis les petits
plats dans les grands on a diversifié en
fait notre offre de restauration on a un
restaurant d'entreprise mais on a aussi
un coffee shop qui est ouvert une bonne
part de la journée dont l'offre évolue
au fil de la journée et on a aussi après
un corner food
cher où là les gens en fait peuvent
commander leurs repas déguster une offre
différente donc on a en fait trois
offres on a une offre diversifiée et
plurielle pour satisfaire un maximum de
convive avec ce réaménagement Sodexo
France peut maintenant accueillir 1200
personnes sur son
[Musique]
site
c-quenttin eneline accueille le tout
premier concept de coiving
d'île-de-fance baptisé le Premium ce
projet devrait regrouper deux immeubles
hybride mélant coiving et coworking né
dans les années 2000 et tout droit venu
des États-Unis cette nouvelle façon de
coabité se développe de plus en plus en
France pour en parler nous sommes avec
Philippe rayer bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directeur et président d'akera
développement ainsi que promoteur de
l'opération oui est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer qu'est-ce que vont
abriter ces deux bâtiments sur ce site
qui est derrière moi on va construire un
ensemble de 13000 m²r composé en été de
deux unités il y a une opération de
coliving colorking de 10000 m² pour
Babel community qui va regrouper 245
chambres
hôtelières aux jeunes actifs et un
immeuble de 3000 m² de bureau
indépendant avec des
prestations en rapport avec la situation
c'estd tout proche de la gare qui sera
destiné donc à un utilisateur unique ou
à des multiutilisateurs et concrètement
en construisant ces deux bâtiment
qu'est-ce que vous proposez comme offre
qu'est-ce qu' va y avoir à l'intérieur
c'est un immeuble indépendant de coiving
et de coworking avec un service hôtelier
restauration salle de sport et au
rez-de-chaussée au dernier étage il y a
des mètres carrés qui sont destinés à
qui sont ouverts à l'extérieur en
coworking donc c'est le le concept de de
bureau partagés et ensuite sur le
deuxième immeuble qui est cé qui est
mais qui est indépendant qui va faire
3000 m² qui s'appelle le Premium enfin
l'ensemble c'est le Premium c'est un
petit imuble de bureau qui fait 3000 m
Carr sur 8 étages avec des vues qui sont
superbes vues sur la gare et vu sur le
le sud de 550 an000 Lig et qui sera
destiné à des PME PMI dans le cadre si
possible d'une acquisition aujourd'hui
la toute première pierre du projet
premium a été déposé au cœur de
l'hypercentre de 50 an en iveline ce
projet il a notamment été mené par the
Babel community donc aujourd'hui je suis
avec Benoît jaobbert vous êtes président
de the Babel community bonjour bonjour
alors est-ce que vous pouvez d'abord
nous expliquer en quoi consiste ce tout
nouveau concept de colivine qui est le
premier à voir le jour en Île-de-France
le concept Babel c'est un concept de
bâtiment hybride qui mène à la fois de
l'hébergement mais également du
coworking un restaurant une salle de
sport beaucoup d'événements un lieu
propice à la rencontre puisque nos
clients se rencontrent au sein d'espace
commun d'espace collectif très nombreux
du sport du restaurant mais également
plein d'espaces communs des jardins
partagés au sein même du même bâtiment
et à qui s'adresse ce concept de
coliving alors il s'adresse à tout le
monde mais mais globalement c'est avant
tout une réponse à la à la difficulté de
se loger dans les grandes métropoles
notamment de la part des jeunes actifs
qui sont à la recherche de deux choses
qui sont à la recherche de logement
flexible sans engagement ils savent pas
forcément combien de temps ils vont
avoir besoin de ce logement faut que ce
logement soit équipé meublé avec des
services et puis faut que ce soit un
logement dans lequel ils vont pouvoir
rencontrer du monde on l'a vraiment
pensé non pas comme une chambre d'hôtel
mais comme un véritable appartement pour
y vivre plusieurs mois pour même
plusieurs années et donc c'est le
premier coiving d'île-de-fance et
pourquoi vous avez choisi monini
bretonux qu'est-ce qui vous a amené
jusqu'ici on a ici eu l'occasion de
rencontrer les équipes d'akera un
promoteur qui a su nous convaincre sur
le D
la du territoire et puis des élus qui
nous ont expliqué à quel point les
entreprises locales avaient des
problématiques d'hébergement et qu'il
était très important d'essayer de les
loger sur place et non pas ailleurs et
c'est assez rapidement qu'on a été
convaincu et qu'on a convaincu notre
partenaire la Caisse des dépôts qui est
aujourd'hui notre coinvestisseur merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
merci bonjour je suis François Xavier
ststeiner j'ai 38 ans et je suis le
fondateur de sitroom sitroom c'est une
plateforme géographique collaborative
qui permet de faciliter la coordination
entre les équipes grâce à un système
collaboratif autour d'une carte
[Musique]
géographique on a fondé l'entreprise en
2020 en octobre 2020 évidemment le
projet remonte un peu avant mais la la
Fondation d'entreprise a eu lieu à ce
moment-là et donc on arrive à 3 ans de
de création actuellement nous sommes
trois associés qui travaillons sur le le
projet un associé technique un associé
plutôt sur le développement commercial
et l'international et moi-même pour la
partie gestion et ensuite on travaille
principalement avec des prestataires qui
qui nous permettent de de développer
[Musique]
l'application l'idée initiale elle est
venue mon expérience je suis un ancien
officier de de l'armée de terre donc
j'ai coordonné des troupes et des
équipes sur le terrain et j'ai je les ai
également coordonné parfois sur le
terrain également à distance et il
manquait d'un outil simple et
collaboratif pour avoir une vision
commune en fait d'une activité en
l'occurrence d'une opération donc c'est
vraiment l'idée initiale et et ensuite
l'idée de le diffuser plutôt dans le
secteur privé initialement afin de
faciliter la coordination des
[Musique]
équipes le logiciel en lui-même permet
de produire des groupes collaboratifs
autour de la
donc l'idée c'est permettre aux
utilisateurs notamment la cible c'est
les coordinateurs de créer des sortes de
groupes collaboratif un peu comme un
WhatsApp en fait mais autour d'une carte
géographique donc on peut saisir de
l'information géoréférencée sur la carte
dans les options disponible on peut
mettre des objets connectés pour avoir
de la remontée en temps réel et
également on a une sorte de chat en fait
commun qui permet aussi d'échanger de
l'information de manière très
[Musique]
libre actuellement on se déploie sur
plusieurs segments euh un segment plutôt
sûreté à destination des des directions
sûreté de tout types d'organisation donc
typiquement on a un client qui a une ONG
par exemple l'objectif c'est de leur
fournir un outil simplifié qui leur
permet de faciliter la coordination de
leurs équipes sur le terrain mais
également de faire de la veille par
exemple d'événements donc ce segment
sûreté en fait nous a permis de
participer au trophé de la sécurité en
septembre et nous avons eu la la joie
d'être lauréador dans la dans la
catégorie des systèmes d'aide à la
décision c'est la fin de ce numéro merci
de l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur
[Musique]
tv78